hello and welcome to machine learning
tutorial part 1 this is part 1 of a
machine learning series put on by simply
learning my name is Richard Kirchner I'm
with the simply learned team that's WW
simply learn comm get certified get
ahead what's in it for you today well
we'll start off with a brief explanation
of why machine learning and what is
machine learning and then we'll get into
a few of the types of machine learning
machine learning algorithms linear
regression decision trees support vector
machine and finally we'll do a use case
where we're gonna classify whether their
recipe is of a cupcake or a muffin using
the SVM or the support vector machine
sounds like a delicious way to explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us
well because machines can now drive your
car for you still very in the infinite
stage but it's just exploding as we see
with Google's way MO and then uber head
their program which unfortunately
crashed they know that this is huge this
is gonna be the huge industry to change
our whole transportation infrastructure
machine learning is now use detect over
50 eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that
double-checks for the doctor for things
they might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that within
some areas where maybe not for eyes but
for other diseases where they're using
the camera on your phone to help pre
diagnose before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face I mean
this is cool having it being able to
identify your face or your voice and
build it turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation the world we live in and as
we dig in deeper we have a nice example
of Facebook as you can see here they
have the Facebook post with Halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam post on Facebook that
annoy them into interacting with likes
shares comments and other actions
I remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here you will have
bad luck or some kind of fear factor
well this is a huge thing in a social
when people are getting spammed and so
this tactic known as engagement bait
takes advantage of Facebook's news feed
algorithm by choosing engagement in
order to get the greater reach to
eliminate engagement bait the company
reviewed and categorized hundreds of
thousands of posts to train a machine
learning model that detects different
types of engagement baked so in this
case we have we're using Facebook but
this is of course across all the
different social media they have
different tools or building and the
Facebook scroll jiff will be replaced
kind of like a virus coming in there and
notices that there's a certain set up
with Facebook and it's able to replace
it and they have like vote baiting react
baiting share baiting they have all
these different these are kind of
general titles but there certainly are a
lot of way of baiting you to go in there
and click on something so they fed all
this this data was fed into the machine
and then they have the new post the new
post comes up that takes over a part of
the Facebook set up and that's what
you're looking at you're looking at this
new post it's replaced like a viruses
replace that so at Facebook to eliminate
this as they start scanning for key
words and phrases like this and checks
the click-through rate so starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
Facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport and a lot of countries you have
like hundreds of people trying to sell
you timeshare come join us sign up for
this eliminates that annoyed us or now
you can just enjoy your Facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures - family certainly
people like their cat pictures - another
good example is google's deepmind
project alphago a computer program that
plays a board game go has defeated the
world's number one go player and i hope
i say his name right qiji the ultimate
go challenge game a three of three was
on May 27th 2017 so it's just last year
that this happened and what makes this
so important is that you know go is just
is a game so it's not like you're
driving a car or something in our real
world but they are using games to learn
how to get the machine learning program
to
they wanted to learn how to learn and
that is a huge step a lot of this is
still in its infant stage as far as
development as we saw what happened with
the as I referred to earlier the uber
cars they lost their whole division
because they jumped ahead too fast so it
still an infant stage but boy is this
like the beginning of just an amazing
world that is automated in ways we can't
even imagine what tomorrow is gonna look
like we've looked at a lot of examples
of machine learning so let's see if we
can give a little bit more of a concrete
definition what is machine learning
machine learning is the science of
making computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and information
without being explicitly programmed we
see here we have a nice little diagram
where we have our ordinary system your
computer nowadays you can even run a lot
of stuff on a cell phone because cell
phones would band so much and then with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it now takes the data and it
learns for what happened before and then
it predicts what's going to come next
and then really the biggest part right
now in machine learning that's going on
is it improves on that how do we find a
new solution so we go from descriptive
words learning about stuff and
understanding how it fits together to
predicting what it's going to do to post
cryptic coming up with a new solution
and when we're working on machine
learning there's a number of different
diagrams that people have posted for
what steps to go through a lot of it
might be very domain-specific so if
you're working on photo identification
versus language versus medical or
physics some of these are switched
around a little bit or new things are
put in they're very specific to the
domain this is kind of a very general
diagram first you want to define your
objective very important to know what it
is you're wanting to predict then you're
going to be collecting the data
so once you've defined an objective you
need to collect the data that matches
you spend a lot of time and data science
collecting data and the next step
preparing the data you got to make sure
that your data is clean going in there's
the old saying bad data in bad answer
out or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we cleaned all this
stuff coming in then you're going to
select the algorithm
which algorithm are you gonna use you're
gonna train that algorithm in this case
I think we're gonna be working with SVM
the support vector machine then you have
to test the model does this model work
is this a valid model for what we're
doing and then once you've tested it you
want to run your prediction you want to
run your prediction or your choice or
whatever output it's gonna come up with
and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing then you
want to go ahead and deploy the model
remember I said domain-specific this is
very general as far as the scope of
doing something a lot of models you get
halfway through you realize that your
data is missing something and you have
to go collect new data because you've
run a test in here someplace along the
line you're saying hey I'm not really
getting the answers I need
there's a lot of things that are
domain-specific they become part of this
model this is a very general model
that's a very good model to start with
and we do have some basic divisions of
what machine learning does that's
important to know for instance do you
want to predict a category well if
you're categorizing thing that's
classification for instance whether the
stock prices will increase or decrease
so in other words I'm looking for a
yes/no answer is it going up or is it
going down and in that case we'd
actually say is it going up true if it's
not going up it's false meaning it's
going down this way is yes/no 0 1 do you
want to predict a quantity that's
regression so remember we just did
classification now we're looking at
regression these are the two major
divisions and what data is doing for
instance predicting the age of a person
based on the height weight health and
other factors so based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is and then there are a lot
of domain-specific things like do you
want to detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now
for instance you want to detect money
withdrawal anomalies you know when
someone's making it withdrawal that
might not be their own account we've
actually brought this up because this is
really big right now if you're
predicting the stock whether to buy
stock or not you want to be able to know
if what's going on in the stock market
is an anomaly use a different prediction
model because something else is going on
you got to pull out new information in
there or is this just the norm I'm gonna
get my normal return on my money
invested so being L detect anomalies is
very big in data science
dey's another question that comes up
which is on what we call untrained data
is do you want to discover structure in
unexplored data and that's called
clustering for instance finding groups
of customers with similar behavior given
a large database of customer data
containing their demographics and past
buying records and in this case we might
notice that anybody who's wearing
certain set of shoes go shopping at
certain stores or whatever it is they're
gonna make certain purchases by having
that information it helps us to market
or group people together so that we can
now explore that group and find out what
it is we want to market to them if
you're in the marketing world and that
might also work in just about any arena
you might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and investments and financial
background whether you're gonna give
them a loan or not before we even start
looking at whether they're valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on Unknowing
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is gonna tell you but you want
to cluster people together that come
together let's take a quick detour for
quiz time oh my favorite so we're gonna
have a couple questions here and there
are quiz time and we'll be posting the
answers in these part two of this
tutorial so let's go ahead and take a
look at these quiz times questions
hopefully you'll get them all right
we'll get you thinking about how to
process data and what's going on can you
tell what's happening in the following
cases of course you're sitting there
with your cup of coffee and your check
box and your PIN trying to figure out
what's your next step in your data
science analysis so the first one is
grouping documents into different
categories based on the topic and
content of each document very big these
days you have legal documents maybe it's
a sports group documents when you are
analyzing newspaper postings but
certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world be
identifying handwritten digits in images
correctly so we want to know whether
they're writing an A or capital ABC what
are they writing out in your hand if
they're Henry
see behavior a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed d
predicting salary of an individual based
on his or her years of experience with
HR hiring set up their so stay tuned for
part two go ahead and answer these
questions when you get to the part two
of this tutorial
or you can just simply write at the
bottom and send a note to simply learn
and they'll follow up with you on it
back to our regular content at least
last few bring us into the next topic
which is another way of dividing our
types of machine learning and that is
with supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on label
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jumble of data with
circles triangles and squares when we
label yeah what's a circle what's a
triangle what's a square and we have our
model training and it trains it so we
know the answer very important when
you're doing supervised learning you
already know the answer to a lot of your
information coming in so you have a huge
group of data coming in and then you
have new data coming in so we've trained
our model the model now knows the
difference between a circle a square a
triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case s Square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one is a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan so
it's talking about banks earlier
supervised learning on stock market
whether you're gonna make money or not
that's always important and if you are
looking to make a fortune in the stock
market keep in mind it is very difficult
to get all the data correct on the stock
market it is very it fluctuates in ways
you really hard to predict so it's quite
a rollercoaster ride if you're running
machine learning on the stock market you
start realizing you really have to dig
for new data so we have supervised
learning and if you have supervised we
should need unsupervised learning in
unsupervised learning machine learning
model finds the hidden pattern in an
unlabeled data so in this case it's
telling it what the circle
what a triangle is and what a square is
it goes in there looks at him and says
for whatever reason it groups them
together
maybe I'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners and number
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have in
common maybe you have one of them who's
a customer at your store or you have 500
more customer your store and they have a
lot in common with five others who are
not customers at your store how do you
market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demographic of who's going to shop there
and you'd like them to shop at your
store nothing one next door of course
this is a simplified version you can see
very easily the difference between a
triangle the circle which is might not
be so easy and marketing reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is an
important type of machine learning or an
agent out ehave in an environment by
performing actions and seeing the result
we have here where the in this case a
baby it's actually great that they used
an infant for this slide because the
reinforcement learning is very much in
its infant stages but it's also probably
the biggest machine learning demand out
there right now or in the future it's
gonna be coming up over the next few
years is reinforcement learning and how
to make that work for us and you can see
here where we have our action in the
action and this one it goes into the
fire
hopefully the baby didn't just a little
candle not a giant fire pit like it
looks like here when the baby comes out
and the new state is the baby is sad and
crying because he got burned on the fire
and then maybe they take another action
baby is called the agent because it's
the one taking the actions and in this
case they didn't go into the fire they
go in a different direction and now the
baby's happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you burn yourself on the
stove don't do that anymore don't touch
the stove in the big picture being able
to have machine learning program under
an AI be able to do this is huge
because now is starting to learn how to
learn that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine
and we're gonna go back and just kind of
go back over supervised versus
unsupervised learning understanding this
is huge because this is gonna come up in
any project you're working on we have in
supervised learning we have labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there said yes that's a
triangle no that's not a triangle can
they be predicted outcome so you have a
nice prediction this is this new set of
data is coming in and we know it is
going to be and then with unsupervised
training it's not labeled so we really
don't know what it is there's no
feedback so we're not telling it whether
it's right or wrong we're not telling it
whether it's a triangle or a square
we're not telling it to go left or right
all we do is we're finding hidden
structure in the data grouping the data
together to find out what connects to
each other and you can use these
together so imagine you have an image
and you're not sure what you're looking
for so you go in and you have the
unstructured data find all these things
that are connected together and then
somebody looks at those and labels up
now you can take that label data and
program something to predict what's in
the picture so you can see how they go
back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them healthy this give you a little
flavor what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support vector machine let's start
with a closer look at linear regression
linear regression is perhaps one of the
most well-known and well-understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning linear regression is a linear
model for example a model that assumes a
linear relationship between the input
variables X and the single output
variable Y and you'll see this if you
remember from your algebra classes y
equals MX plus C imagine we are
predicting distance traveled Y from
speed X our linear regression model
representation for this problem would be
y equals M times X plus C or distance
equals M times speed plus C where m is
the coefficient and C is the y-intercept
and we're going to look at two different
variations of the
first we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness speed equals ten meters
per second and so over a certain amount
of time his distance equals 36
kilometers we have a second bicyclist is
going twice the speed or 20 meters per
second and you can guess if he's going
twice the speed and time is a constant
then he's gonna go twice the distance
and that's easily to compute 36 times 2
you get 72 kilometers and so if he had
the question of how fast would somebody
is going three times at speed or 30
meters per second is you can easily
compute the distance in our head we can
do that without needing a computer but
we're going to do this for more
complicated data so it's kind of nice to
compare the two but let's just take a
look at that and what that looks like in
a graph so in a linear regression model
we have our distance to the speed and we
have our M equals the ve slope of the
line and we'll notice that the line has
a plus slope and as speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals MX plus C just has
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing as
three times ten meters per second this
is roughly 102 kilometers distance that
this third bicyclist has traveled one of
the key definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so does
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second they have a certain
distance to go and it takes them a
hundred seconds to travel that distance
and we have our second bicyclist who's
still doing 20 meters per second since
he's going twice the speed we can guess
he'll cover the distance in about half
the time 50 seconds and of course you
could probably guess on the third one a
hundred divided by 30 since he's going 3
times the speed you can easily guess
that this is thirty three point three
three three seconds time we put that
into a linear regression model or a
graph if the distance is assumed to be
constant let's see the relationship
between speed and time and as time goes
up the amount of speed to go that same
distance
down so now your M equals a minus ve
slope of the line as the speed increases
time decreases
hence the variable has a negative
relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship depended on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this and even a significant
amount of data let's see with the
mathematical implementation of linear
regression and we'll take this data so
suppose we have this data set where we
have XY x equals one two three four five
standard series and the Y value is three
two two four three when we take that and
we go ahead and plot these points on a
graph you can see there's kind of a nice
scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is we come up here we have
the mean of X I and remember mean is
basically the average so we added five
plus four plus three plus three plus one
and divide by five that simply comes out
as three and then we'll do the same for
y we'll go ahead and add up all those
numbers and divide by five and we end up
with the mean value of y of I equals 2.8
where the X I reference is an average or
means value and the Y I also mean khals
a means value of y and when we plot that
you'll see that we can put in the y
equals 2.8 and the x equals 3 in there
on our graph when we kind of give it a
little different color so you could sort
it out with the dashed lines on it and
it's important to note that when we do
the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot now let's find our regression
equation to find the best fit line we go
ahead and take our y equals MX plus C so
we're looking for M and C so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of M and our coefficient
of C and we have y equals MX plus C
where M equals the sum of X minus X
average times y minus y average or Y
means and X means over the sum of x
minus x means squared that's how we get
the slope of the value of the line and
we can easily do that by creating some
columns here we have XY computers are
really good about iterating through data
and so we can easily compute this and
fill in a graph of data and in our graph
you can easily see that if we have our x
value of 1 and if you remember the X I
or the means value is 3 1 minus 3 equals
a negative 2 and 2 minus 3 equals a
negative 1 so on and so forth and we can
easily fill in the column of X minus X I
Y minus y I and then from those we can
compute X minus X I squared and X minus
X I times y minus y I and you can guess
it that the next step is to go ahead and
sum the different columns for the
answers we need so we get a total of 10
for our X minus X I squared and a total
of 2 for X minus X I times y minus y I
and we plug those in we get 2/10 which
equals point 2 so now we know the slope
of our line equals point 2 so we can
calculate the value of C that be the
next step is we need to know where it
crosses the y axis and if you remember I
mentioned earlier that the linear
regression line has to pass through the
means value 1 that we showed earlier we
can just flip back up there to that
graph and you can see right here there's
our means value which is 3 x equals 3
and y equals 2.8 and since we know that
value we can simply plug that into our
formula y equals point 2 X plus C so we
plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2 times
3 plus C and you can just solve for C so
now we know that our coefficient equals
to point 2 and once we have all that we
can go ahead and plot our regression
line y equals 0.2 times X plus 2 point 2
and then from this equation we can
compute new values so let's predict the
values of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5 and
plot the points remember the 1 2 3 4 5
was our original X values so now we're
gonna see what Y thinks they are not
what they actually are and we plug those
in we get Y I've designated with Y of P
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2
point 4 x equals 2 equals 2 point 6 and
so on and so on
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think is going to be we put
those numbers in and when we plot the
values along with the actual values we
can see the difference and this is one
of the things it's very important with
linear regression and any of these
models is to understand the error and so
we can calculate the error on all of our
different values and you can see over
here we plotted x and y and y predict
and we draw it a little lines you can
sort of see what the error looks like
there between the different points so
our goal is to reduce this error we want
to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
square distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same and gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals MX plus C but you
can take that out to X Z ijq all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems in the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents the possible
decision or currents or reaction we have
data which tells us if it is a good day
to play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spreadsheet you can
see we have the outlook whether it's
rainy overcast sunny temperature hot
mild cool humidity windy and did I like
to play golf that day yes or no so we're
taking a census and certainly I wouldn't
want a computer telling me when I should
go play golf or not but you could
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that
it's becomes very beneficial and we see
this a lot
applications coming out now where it
gives you suggestions and lets you know
what would fit the match for you for the
next day or the next purchase or the
next whatever you know next meal out in
this case is tomorrow a good day for
playing golf based on the weather coming
in and so we come up and let's determine
if you should play golf when the day is
sunny and windy so we found out the
forecast tomorrow is going to be sunny
and windy and suppose we draw our tree
like this we're gonna have our humidity
and then we have our normal which is if
it's if you have a normal humidity
you're gonna go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the outlook and if the outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's gonna change what
you choose to do so if you know that
it's a very high humidity and it's sunny
you're probably not gonna play golf
because you're gonna be out there
miserable fighting off the mosquitoes
that are out joining you to play golf
with you maybe if it's rainy you
probably don't wanna play in the rain
but if it's slightly overcast and you
get just the right shadow that's a good
day to play golf and be outside out on
the green now in this example you can
probably make your own tree pretty
easily excessive airy simple set of data
going in but the question is how do you
know what to split where do you split
your data what if this is much more
complicated data where it's not
something that you would particularly
understand like studying cancer they
take about 36 measurements of the
cancerous cells and then each one of
those measurements represents somehow
bulbus it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but so that's the questions going
to come up is this the right decision
tree for that we should calculate
entropy and information gain two
important vocabulary words zero the
entropy and the information gain entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
impurity in the data set entropy should
be low so we want the chaos to be as low
as possible we don't want to look at it
and be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data and the
information gained it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as I of P eV and
in where P is the probability that
you're going to play a game of golf and
in is the probability where you're not
going to play the game of golf now you
don't really have to memorize these
formulas there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming
unless you're building your own decision
tree code in the back and we simply have
a log squared of P over P plus n minus n
over P plus n times the log square root
of n P plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side and to be of a target class
of the data set is the whole entropy so
we have entropy play golf and we look at
this if we go back to the data you can
simply count how many yeses and no in
our complete data set for playing golf
days in our complete set we find we have
5 days we did play golf and nine days we
did not play golf and so our I equals if
you have those together at 9 plus 5 is
14 and so our I equals 5 over 14 and 9
over 14 that's our P and n values we
plug into that formula and you can go 5
over 14 equals 0.36 9 over 14 equals 0.6
for and when you do the whole equation
you get the minus 0.36 log square root
of 0.36 minus 0.64 log squared root of
0.6 4 and we get a set value we get to
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for a
playing golf and the outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have P of
sunny times E of 3 of 2 and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is five don't forget
we'll divide that fine but later on I
equals P overcast equals 4 comma 0 plus
rainy equals 2 comma 3 and then when you
do the whole setup we have 5 over 14
remember I said there was a total of 5 5
over 14 times the I of 3 of 2 plus 4
over 14 times the 4 comma 0 and 5 14
over I of 2 3 and so we can now compute
the entropy of just the part it has to
do with the forecast and we get 0.693
similarly we can calculate the entropy
of other predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain outlook how much are we going to
gain from this entropy play golf minus
entropy play golf outlook and we can
take the original 0.94 for the whole set
minus the entropy of just the rainy day
and temperature and we end up with a
gain of 0.2 for 7 so this is our
information gain remember we define
entropy and we define an information
gain the higher the information gain the
lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way so we have our gain for temperature
equals 0.029 we have our gain for
humidity equals 0.152 and our gain for a
windy day equals 0.048 and if you do a
quick comparison you'll see the point
two four seven is the greatest gain of
information so that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as a root node and then continue to
split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our all look we split it three
different directions
if the outlook is overcast we're gonna
play and then we can split those further
down if we want so if the overall look
is sunny but then it's also windy if
it's windy we're not going to play if it
not Wendy will play so we can easily
build a nice decision tree to guess what
we would like to do tomorrow and give us
a nice recommendation for the day
so we want to know if it's a good day to
play golf when it's sunny and windy
remember the original question that came
out tomorrow's weather report is sunny
and windy you can see by going down the
tree we go out look sunny outlook Wendy
we're not gonna play golf tomorrow so
our little SmartWatch pops up and says
I'm sorry
tomorrow is not a good day for golf it's
gonna be sunny and windy and if you're a
huge golf and you might go oh it's not a
good day to play golf we can go in and
watch a golf game at home so we'll sit
in front of the TV instead of being out
playing golf in the wind now that we've
looked at our decision tree let's look
at the third one of our algorithms were
investigating support vector machine
support vector machine is a widely used
classification algorithm the ideas
support vector machine is simple the
algorithm creates a separation line
which divides the classes in the best
possible manner for example dog or cat
disease or no disease suppose we have a
labelled sample data which tells height
and weight of males and females a new
data point arrives and we want to know
whether it's going to be a male or a
female so we start by drawing a line we
draw decision lines but if we consider
decision line one then we will classify
the individual as a male and if we
consider decision line two then it'll be
a female so you can see this person kind
of lies in the middle of the two groups
was a little confusing trying to figure
out which line they should be under we
need to know which line divides the
classes correctly but how the goal is to
choose a hyperplane and that is one of
the key words they use we talk about
support vector machines choose a
hyperplane with the greatest possible
margin between the decision line and the
nearest point within the training set so
you can see here we have our support
vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equally distant between the two points
that we're comparing it to when we draw
the hyperplanes
we observe that line 1 has a maximum
distance so we observed that line 1 has
a map
from distance margins so we'll classify
the new data point correctly and our
result on this one is going to be that
the new data point is mel one of the
reasons we call it a hyperplane versus a
line is that a lot of times we're not
looking at just weight and height we
might be looking at 36 different
features or dimensions and so when we
cut it with a hyperplane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data or
multi-dimensional that cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example problem statement I
always start with a problem statement
when you're gonna put some code together
we're gonna do some coding now
classifying muffin and cupcake recipes
using support vector machines so the
cupcake versus the muffin let's have a
look at our data set and we have the
different recipes here we have a muffin
recipe that has so much flour I'm not
sure what measurement 55 is in but it
has 55 its ounces but has certain amount
of flour certain amount of milk sugar
butter egg baking powder vanilla and
salt and so based on these measurements
we want to guess whether we're making a
muffin or a cupcake and you can see in
this one we don't have just two features
we don't just have height and weight as
we did before between the male and
female in here we have a number of
features in fact in this we're looking
at eight different features to guess
whether it's a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake
it turns out muffins have more flour
while cupcakes have more butter and
sugar so basically the cupcakes a little
bit more of a dessert where the muffins
a little bit more of a fancy bread but
how do we do that in Python how do we
code that to go through recipes and
figure out what the recipe is and I
really just want to say cupcakes versus
muffins like some big professional
wrestling thing before we started in our
cupcakes versus muffins we are going to
be working in Python there's many
versions of Python many different
editors that is one of the strengths and
weaknesses of Python is it just has so
much stuff attached to it it's one of
the more popular data science
programming packages you can use in
this case we're gonna go ahead and use
anaconda in Jupiter NOPA the anaconda
navigator has all kinds of fun tools
once you're into the Anaconda navigator
you can change environments I actually
have a number of environments on here
we'll be using Python 3 6 environment so
this is in Python version 3 6 although
it doesn't matter too much which version
you use I usually try to stay with the
3x because they're current unless you
have a project that's very specifically
in version 2x - 7 I think is usually
what most people use in the version 2
and then once we're in our Jupiter
notebook editor I can go up and create a
new file just jump in here in this case
we're doing svm muffin vs. cupcake and
then let's start with our packages for
data analysis and we almost always use a
couple there's a few very standard
packages we use we use important port
import numpy that's for number Python
leaves they denote it as NP that's very
comma that's very common and then we're
gonna import pandas as PD it numpy deals
with number arrays there's a lot of cool
things you can do with the numpy setup
as far as multiplying all the values in
an array to numpy array data array
pandas I came here if we're using it
actually in this data set I think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is it a data frame
it's more like your Excel spreadsheet
you have columns you have indexes you
have different ways of referencing it
easily viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine so from SK alert
we're gonna use the SK learn model
import SVM support vector machine and
then there's a data scientist you should
always try to visualize your data some
data obviously is too complicated or
doesn't make any sense to the human but
if it's possible it's going to take a
second look at it so she can actually
see what you're doing now for that we're
going to use two packages we're going to
import map plot library PI plot as p LT
again very common and we're going to
import Seabourn as SN s and we'll go
ahead and set the font scale in the s
and s right in our import line that's
what this semi colon followed by a line
of data we're gonna set the SNS and
these are great because the Seabourn
sits on top of mat plot library just
like pandas hits on num P so it adds a
lot more features and uses and control
we're obviously not going to get into
mat flat library and Seabourn there'd be
its own tutorial we're really just
focusing on the SVM the support vector
machine from SK learn and since we're in
Jupiter notebook we have to add a
special line in here for our Met plot
library and that's your percentage sign
or amber sign mat plot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project a lot of times I
use like notepad plus plus and I'll read
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your computer
setup because we're writing this in the
Jupiter notebook as a browser setup this
tells it to display all of our graphics
right below on the page so that's what
that line is for or the first time I ran
this I didn't know that and to look that
up years ago it's quite a headache so
mat plot library in line is just because
we're running this on the web setup and
we can go ahead and run this make sure
all our modules are in there all
important which is great if you don't
have them import you'll need to go ahead
and pip use the VIP or however you do it
there's a lot of other install packages
out there although pip is the most
common
and you have to make sure these are all
installed on your Python setup the next
step of course is we got to look at the
data can't run hey model for predicting
data if you don't have actual data so to
do that let me go ahead and open this up
and take a look and we have our cupcakes
versus muffins and it's a CSV file or
dot CSV meaning that it's comma
separated variable I'm just gonna open
it up in a nice spreadsheet for me and
you can see up here we have the type we
have a muffin muffin muffin cupcake
cupcake cupcake and then it's broken up
into flour milk sugar butter egg baking
powder vanilla and salt so we can do is
we can go ahead and look at this data
also in our Python let us create a
variable recipes equals we're going to
use our pandas module dot read csv
member is a comma separated variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins obviously got
double brackets there do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program are loaded or the
the place I saved this particular Python
program is in the same folder we can get
by with just the file name but remember
if you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on there
and then because we're in pandas we're
gonna go ahead and conditionally in line
you can do this but let me do the full
print you can just type in recipes head
in the jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes head and pandas nose
is that's gonna do the first five lines
of data and if we flip back on over to
the spreadsheet where we opened up our
csv file you can see where it starts on
line two
this one calls it zero and then two
three four five six is gonna match go
and close that out we don't need that
anymore and i always starts at zero and
these are it automatically indexes it
since we didn't tell it to use an index
in here so that's the index number for
the left hand side and it automatically
took the top row as labels so pandas
using it to read a csv is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas not just because they're
cute and cuddly teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data I'm
not gonna plot all of it I'm just gonna
plot the sugar and flour now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features and so you'll break them up and
maybe look at just two of them at a time
to see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use Seaborn so that's our SNS and
the command for that is SNS LM plot and
then the two different variables I'm
going to plot is flour and sugar data
equals recipes the hue equals type and
this is a lot of fun because it knows
that this is pandas coming in and so
this is one of the powerful things about
panda is mixed with Seaborn in doing
graphic
then we're gonna use a pallet set one
there's a lot of different sets in there
you can go look them up for Seaborn
we're doing a regular regular equals
false so we're not really trying to fit
anything and it's a scatter kws a lot of
these settings you can look up in
Seaborn have these you could probably
leave off when you run them somebody
played with this and found out that
these were the best settings for doing a
Seaborn plot let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line he just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split and we use
these models because you can actually
look at it and say hey if I drew a line
right between the middle of blue dots
and the red dots we'd be able to do an
SVM and a hyperplane right there in the
middle
then the next step is to format or pre
our data
and we're going to break that up into
two parts
we need a type label and remember we're
gonna decide whether it's a muffin or
cupcake while a computer doesn't know
muffin or cupcake it knows zero and one
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
create a type label from this will
create a numpy array and P where and
this is where we can do some logic we
take our recipes from our Panda and
wherever a type equals muffin that's
going to be zero and then if it doesn't
equal muffin which is cupcakes it's
going to be one so we create our type
label this is the answer so when we're
doing our training model remember we
have to have a training data this is
what we're gonna train it with is that
it's zero or one it's a muffin or it's
not
and then we're going to create our
recipe features and if you remember
correctly from right up here the first
column is tight
so we really don't need the type call
because that's our muffin or cupcake and
in pandas we can easily sort that out
we take our value recipes dot-coms
that's a panda's function built in the
pandas
without values from burning them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top and we don't want
the first one so what we do is it always
starts at zero we want one colon till
the end and then we want to go ahead and
make this a list and this converts it to
a list of strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right go
ahead and run that and I forgot the s on
recipes so we'll go ahead and add the s
in there and then run that and we can
see we have flour milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and that
matches what we have up here we print it
out everything but the type so we have
our features and we have our label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns we actually need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients and you're doing this
usually you do but for our example we
want to limit it so you can easily see
what's going on because if we did all
the ingredients we have you know that's
what seven eight different hyperplanes
that would be built into it we only want
to look at one so you can see what the
SVM is doing and so we'll take our
recipes and we'll do just a little flour
and sugar again you can replace that
with your recipe features and do all of
them but we're gonna do just flour and
sugar and we're going to convert that to
values we don't need to make a list out
of it because it's not string values
these are actual values on there and we
can go ahead and just print ingredients
you can see what that looks like and so
we have just an amount of flour and
sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and take our recipe
features
so if we decided to use all the recipe
features you'll see that it makes a nice
column of different data so just strips
out all the labels and everything we
just have just the values but because we
want to be able to view this easily in a
plot later on we'll go ahead and take
that and just do flour and sugar
and we'll run that you'll see it's just
the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model we'll go ahead just call it
model and it's an SVM we're using a
package called SV see
in this case we're gonna go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific set up on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the SVM you'll see that there is
about there's eight of them here three
of them are for regression three are for
classification the SVC support vector
classification is probably one the most
commonly used and there is also one for
detecting outliers and another one that
has to do with something a bit more
specific on the model but SVC and svr
are the two most commonly used standing
for support vector classifier and
support vector regression remember
regression is an actual value a float
value or whatever you're trying to work
on an SBC is a classifier so it's a
yes/no true/false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake we go ahead and create
our model and once we have our model
created we're gonna do model dot fit and
this is very common especially in the SK
learn all their models are followed with
the fit command and when we put into the
fit or we're training with it as we're
putting in the ingredients which in this
case we limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where 1/3 is used for
whether you switch between which ones
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that it gets very
complicated I'm gonna get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
this is a very simple set of data let's
go ahead and run this and now we have
our model fit and I got an error here so
let me fix that real quick capital SBC
it turns out I did it lower case support
vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that and you'll see it comes up
with all this information that it prints
out automatically these are the defaults
of the model you notice that we changed
the kernel to linear and there's our
kernel linear on the printout there's
other different settings you can mess
with
we're gonna just to leave that alone for
right now for this we don't really need
to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our newly trained model and we're
going to do this so you can show you on
a graph
let's go ahead and get the separating
we're gonna say we're going to use a W
for our variable here we're gonna do
model dot coefficient underscore zero so
what the heck is that
again we're digging into the model so
we've already got a prediction and a
train this is a math behind it that
we're looking at right now
and so the W is can represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals MX plus C so
these coefficients are connected to that
but in two dimensional it's a plane
we don't have spend too much time on
this because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math so if you're a
math whiz this is great you can go
through here and you'll see that we have
a equals minus W of zero over W of 1
remember there's two different values
there and that's basically the slope
that we're generating and then we're
going to build an X X what is X X we're
going to set it up to a numpy array
there's our NP dot line space so we're
creating a line of values between 30 and
60 so it just creates a set of numbers
for X and then if you remember correctly
we have our formula y equals the slope
times X plus the intercept well to make
this work we can do this as Y y equals
the slope times each value in that array
that's the neat thing about numpy so
when I do a times X X which is a whole
number array of values it multiplies a
across all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept in this
area we have MX plus C so that'll be the
C from the formula y equals MX plus C
that's where all these numbers come from
a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it so plot the parallels to
separating hyperplane that pass through
the support vectors and so we're going
to create B equals a model support
vectors pulling our support vectors out
there here's our YY which we now know is
a set of data we have we create YY down
equals a times X X plus b1 minus a times
B 0 and then model support vector B is
going to be set that to a new value the
minus 1 set up and YY up equals a times
X X plus b1 minus a times B 0 and we go
ahead just run this to load these
variables up if you want to know
understand a little bit more of us going
on you can see if we print
yy-you just run that you can see it's a
race this is a line it's gonna have in
this case between 30 and 60 so it's
gonna be 30 variables in here and the
same thing with YY up YY down and we'll
plot those in just a minute on the
graphs you can see what those look like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate I'm just
gonna copy this from before remember
this our SNS Darcy Bourne plot LM plot
flour sugar and I'll just go and run
that real quick so you can see what
remember what that looks like it's just
a straight graph on there
and then one of the new things is
because Seaborn sits on top of PI plot
we can do the PI plot for the line going
through and that is simply P ot dot plot
and that's our xx and YY are two
corresponding values XY and then
somebody played with this to figure out
that the line width equals two and the
color black would look nice so let's go
ahead and run this whole thing with the
pie plot on there and you can see when
we do this it's just doing flour and
sugar on here corresponding line between
the sugar and the flour and the muffin
versus cupcakes
and then we generated the support
vectors the YY down and YY up
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like so do our PL plot and again
this is all against X X our x value but
this time we have YY down and let's do
something a little fun with us we can
put in in K - - that just tells it to
make it a dotted line and if we're going
to do the down one we also want to do
the one so here's our YY
and when we run that both sets a line
and so here's our support and this is
what you use expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
points and dash lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your SVM
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour which one's a muffin or
a cupcake let's go ahead and create a
function to predict muffin or cupcake
I've got my recipes I pulled off the
internet and I want to see the
difference between a muffin or a cupcake
and so we need a function to push that
through and create a function with death
and let's call it muffin or cupcake
remember we're just doing flowers or
sugar today I'm doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients to know it's flour
and sugar and let's go ahead and do an
if-else statement
so if model predict
is a flour and sugar equals zero so we
take our model and we do it run a
predict that's very common in SK clarin
we have a dot predict you put the data
in and it's going to return a value in
this case if it equals zero then print
you're looking at a muffin recipe else
if it's not zero that means it's one
then you're looking at a recipe that's
pretty straightforward for function or
death for definition TEF is how you do
that python and of course we're going to
create a function you should run
something in it and so let's run a
cupcake and we're gonna send it values
50 and 20 a muffin or cupcake I don't
know what it is and let's run this and
just see what it gives us and it says oh
it's a muffin you're looking at a muffin
recipe so it very easily predicts
whether we're looking at a muffin or a
cupcake recipe let's plot this plot this
on the graph so we can see what that
actually looks like and I'm just gonna
copy and paste it from below we're
plotting all the points in there so this
is nothing different than we did before
if I run it you'll see it has all the
points and the lines on there what we
want to do is we want to add another
point the PLT plot
and if you marry correctly we did for
our test we did 5020 and then somebody
went in here and decided we'll do y ou
for yellow or it's kind of a oranges
yellow color it's gonna come out marker
sighs nothing
those are settings you can play with
somebody else played with them to come
up with the right setup so it looks good
and you can see there it is graph
clearly a muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has one and if you'd like to
do your own muffin cupcake contender
series you certainly can send a note
down below and the team at simply learn
will send you over the data they use for
the muffin and cupcake and that's true
of any other data and we didn't actually
run a plot on it earlier we had men
versus women you can also request that
information to run it on your data set
up so you can test that out so to go
back over our setup we went ahead for
our support vector machine code we did a
predict 40 parts flour 20 parts sugar I
think was different than the one we did
whether it's a muffin or a cupcake hence
we have built a classifier using SVM
which is able to classify if a recipe is
of a cupcake or a mod which wraps up our
cupcake versus muffin so the key
takeaways what is machine learning we
discussed that with some of the
different aspects of machine learning on
there we went into types of machine
learning if you memorize we have
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning we discussed
regression line or best fit and we did
the building a decision tree and what
the logic is behind that and finally we
did classification using SVM support
vector machine and we did the code in
there that wraps it up one thank you for
joining us today for more information
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor baaz we
will be monitoring that we might be able
to answer those questions
thank you very much for joining us today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here